all right so what should we start out
with uh
how about how about what's what's not a
high value man
that's the easy thing isn't it that's so
that's the easiest place to begin isn't
it
it's always it's always easy to find
it's always easy to poke like
holes in people's like you know this is
what it's easy to identify what a beta
is it's like
more i think subjective and relative to
to
decide what's alpha because too many
guys want to
individualize it they want to
subjectivize it i guess for themselves
and like ever since i ever since like
day one like from my
from my very earliest essays all the way
up through the first book there's a
whole section on like what is alpha
right the origin of alpha is an essay i
have
uh alpha was just actually the excuse me
the first one
and then like the contextual alpha and
it's like what makes you
what makes you high value and i don't
know why we're just not
simply using the term alpha male because
that's pretty much what everybody's
like debating right now what makes you
high value what not
and yet we're still going to the same
well we're still going to the same
source which is
hey let's ask all these 19 year old
girls what makes you
uh an alpha male right let's let's go
talk to this 30 some odd girl
let's who's you know all used up right
let's go ask
what what do girls really want you know
how long i've
heard that that question asked and it's
always the same answer whatever i am
yeah yeah whatever fits my definition or
it's usually like when you ask women
that what makes a high value guy
it's whatever serves their most
immediate needs
whatever is their most necessities of at
that particular time so if you ask a
girl who's like
19 20 somewhere around there and you say
hey what do you look for in a guy like
what makes a high-value guy she's going
to tell you a completely different thing
than a girl who's like
in her epiphany you know mid epiphany
phase and you always got to have
you know he's got to have prospects he's
got ib on his game he's got like puppy
dogs you got to love his mommy and you
know that kind of crap
and it's like it just depends on what
her priorities are at that at that
particular time so
like i said it's always going to be
easier to point out what isn't
because we have so many examples all
over the place
it's easy to to point that out like you
look at that um
that one tweet i just retweeted not too
long ago but this guy's like
almost in a brazier and he's like you
know looks like he's transgender or
whatever and the guy is just this
i mean he is he he's like pajama boy for
you guys remember who pajama boy was but
you know complete
you know it's not like soy that's all we
talk about is that this is joy that's
soy
um but it's it's these guys who are
still like what
isn't high value to me is still gonna be
about
what's up here like what's your ideology
what is it what do you what's your
belief that i don't even
call it ideology it's like what's your
belief set is
is the most important thing because
that's going to separate you from money
that's going to separate you from women
that's going to separate you from
actually going out and doing some like
ambition that's going to separate you
from passion it's going to separate you
from going to the freaking gym
right it's whatever you whatever you
think if you don't think that there's
any value in going to the gym
it starts up here it's not starting out
like oh well
you know i i you know you don't have
access to the gym you can make up any
reason why you don't do things
but like really where it begins is just
right that that's where the
the beginning of high value is really
sort of in in your belief set
and what you and i know that sounds like
woo-woo magical thinking but
it's what is like what is your operating
condition right what how were you raised
up like
you just did a rich you just did that
thing with a coach kareem is that what
the guy's name is
yeah and like i'm sure they're
like i i talk about whenever i talk with
abu american or i talk about talk to a
guy who's like sort of
a really i don't say orthodox muslim but
is certainly a
practicing or believing muslim they're
always very
specific about what makes uh a prime
masculine guy and it's that's one of the
i think still one of the beauties of the
manosphere is we can still have that
conversation we can
we can sort of compare notes as to like
what makes you alpha what doesn't make
you alpha
yeah nine times out of ten like i said
before is that it's
always going to be whatever your belief
set or your
your your operating state really is
because nobody wants to be told
they suck right nobody wants to be told
you have no
i'm not good you have a lower basically
what you're saying is is
you have a lower possibility of
reproducing
what you're saying and you're happy that
like happiness can be found in
reproducing and having
a family starting a tribe and all that
kind of stuff and it's like
you have to sort of bust yourself down
to zero
again and say what do i believe what
what are my belief sets
now what is it what is it that i think
is valuable
now now that i have now that i'm red
pill aware now that i'm unplugged now
that i'm even if you're not entirely
unplugged like
you your belief sets have changed what's
going to be valuable to you
right now and why and how do you come to
those conclusions
yeah yeah i think it's this intangible
side of somebody's personality that
really makes them high value because
there is a sense particularly in this
space it's all about acquisition it's
all about okay how many girls have you
got
how many cars have you got how much
money have you got all of that and
that's not to say
that a high value man uh university
commerce wouldn't have those things
because obviously value does attract
those things but equally
you could be a dude who's slept with say
1300 women and is a complete douchebag
or you could be a guy
who has made a bunch of money and is a
worthless individual for various reasons
right so
the the things that you've acquired
don't in themselves
make you high value so it's got to be
something else so why is
say rich who's a multi-millionaire is a
high value man
whereas there are other
multi-millionaires who are just complete
dirtbags
you know i was out with somebody else
earlier this week who is known to us in
this sphere
met up briefly um had a nice afternoon
together also
uh very wealthy man multi-millionaire
he's also a high value guy
but he's not a high value guy because of
the stuff he's got he's a high-value guy
because of his personal integrity and i
think i think it's that that we've got
to get down to it
yeah i think a lot of people put way too
much uh
emphasis on success or material things
that have been acquired
as high value oh well he has elon musk
has this business and these cars and all
this money
jeff bezos has all this money and the
success
uh but he doesn't know how to handle
women doesn't have to talk to women he
doesn't know how
to do a lot of things that probably
would would
put him in a position where his life
would be much better than it is even
though he's got
a crapload of money there's plenty of
rich without game
yes you know like money doesn't that
money doesn't cure
blue pill and then and then you know he
got divorced and he got taken for a lot
of money so you can see that
his inadequacy internally led to him
getting
robbed basically same thing with me like
i got you know beaten into some blue
pill stuff
through my marriage and that that ended
up separating me from my
my wealth what if um what if women
throw themselves at a guy
you know let's say he's like a natural
alpha like a corey worthington or some
you know chad we've established pretty
well though that women are pretty
terrible at choosing
yeah because i mean i think it really
depends on who you ask how old they are
what stage of their life they're in if
they're a man or a woman and what their
interpretation is
i mean i'll say this like if if you
gotta
ask questions like um you know how do i
i mean i've seen guys ask questions like
how do i run a harem how do i
you know how do i have a threesome how
do i have multiple girlfriends sort of
thing
and then you kind of take a look at
their life and it's like where they live
what they do for a living what their
income is you know what the level of
game is they've got a notch count of
four or something like that and they
want to run a harem it's like
you need to slow down there sonny boy
you got a little bit of a foundation to
build before you're going to
you know even entertain concepts like
that
you know you got to get some experience
you got to get your knowledge
there's money black belt yeah there's
yeah there's levels it's
it's like you know when you get up to
the black belt you know sort of thing
it's like
i don't know like i've you know like i'm
in my late 40s and i look around at my
life and i run
three seven figure businesses i've got a
lot going on i
make actually most of my money not on
youtube you know despite all the
[ __ ] that i hear
rich made it money off of symf no stupid
outside okay no this is this is what i
do to entertain myself to hang out with
my boys
this is your hobby
[Music]
but i think that's a big thing with a
lot of people nowadays they want to
start at the top
you know like i i had a uh the 16 year
old kid was asking me about life advice
and whatever and
he's talking about how he wants to be an
mma promoter i was like oh well that's
promotion that's sales so find a product
any product and figure out if you can
sell it
if that's step one like don't start
trying to sign fighters and put on this
big production
and do a show like buy an a product any
product
can you sell gum if you can't sell gum
how the hell are you going to sell out
an arena that's cool
yeah like so so i was like do that he's
like well i don't know about that i was
like well then
then uh start organizing uh events with
your friends and people do it for free
see if you can get 30 people to show up
at a park
and and do this event and and if you
can't do that then you're kind of [ __ ]
like if like you know uh you got to
start somewhere
that's funny that's like all i did for
the longest time i still
still kind of do it right now i mean
when i got into liquor like the most
things
like as an art director as a promoter
like i do and promote you know brand
promotions and stuff like that
all of w when i learned how to do that
by the way john is
i learned that in uh playing in bands
because i always had
i was always a guy with artistic talent
so i was the guy who was making the
flyers
use them and like i would make the logos
and everybody loved
the the stuff that i did for my own
bands so they started hitting me up
can you do our flyers you know can you
do our posters can you do our
photography i'm like yeah
yes i can and that's how i
made a good chunk of change when i was
in my mid-20s and yeah so that's a great
example of you put
yourself 100 into a goal but like
other things pop up like your your end
goal for doing that was like to make
your band famous and
performing and do awesome stuff but then
other people saw what you're doing and
then
you had an opportunity to pivot and make
money yeah that's
like no i'm i'm only going to do my band
stuff and i'm going to be tunnel vision
just for my vans but
my most of my understanding of when it
comes i mean i've got
i have formal education now but like
back then i certainly didn't and
it usually came from like just seeing
how things work firsthand like you're
down in the trenches and they're saying
like oh hey will you do our flyers
because flyers are here today and gone
tomorrow right we used to have to
i just have to do them by hand and then
we have to put them on like a xerox
machine and
bang out a whole bunch of them there's
money there's a money me doing it
there's money me reproducing it there's
money
in the distribution of it and i was like
and all it is is just flyers
and this is pretty internet so um just
being down there and experiencing it and
figuring it out on your own
that's another thing i was going to say
an aspect of a high quality guy
is having being clever like
understanding
like seeing seeing patterns like that
that you go
i can make some money off of that or i
can do something with this you you i
think
recognizing opportunity is one of the
key elements of being a high value guy
i'm just going to expand on that because
i talked about this a couple months ago
where
one of the most important predictors of
success in entrepreneurship is having an
ability to solve
problems so to rolo's point
if you want to be high value problems
are going to come at you all day long in
your life gentlemen
it doesn't matter if it's from from work
if you're self-employed if you're
in sales doesn't matter what you're
doing they're going to keep women you
know
guys are all i want to run a hair i'm
going to have 10 like do you understand
how much game you have to have and
how much [ __ ] you money you have to have
to run a harem of 10 women
right because you're going to be putting
up with 10 times more problems than a
regular guy right so
like just understand that being able to
solve problems is an incredibly
important skill when it comes to
creating value for yourself
if you want to you know get up there on
the top shelf if you know what i'm
saying
and uh quick quick shout out to michael
for just reminding guys to hit the like
button thanks
um actually let me grab the link here
i'm going to drop the link if you guys
are on like uh
facebook's or twitter or whatever just
come on over and join us on youtube it
just helps me out thanks
so so a lot of this it comes down to
competency are you competent can you
are you competent with women are you
competent with money are you competent
with friends and relationships
are you competent with not [ __ ] your
life up and
going to jail
yes because because a lot of the things
that you will then acquire will come as
a result of that competency but it's not
the it's not the baubles at the end it's
not the shiny baubles that you end up
with
it's actually the competency itself that
makes the dude high value on or not
because also as well remember people get
stuff falling into their lap don't they
i mean something like the
corey worthington example you know saw a
big suburban house but well it you know
it's his parents so
you know he was able to sort of have
that big party or whatever but
um so you know it's it's really looking
at the core
aspects of yourself as a as a human
being as an effective man that's the
important thing
what about level of income like how
important is that like
do you have to be a top five percent
income earner to be considered a top
shelf man
if you have everything you need no
like if you if you have a farm in in the
midwest somewhere and you own the land
and like you have chickens and you're
throwing fresh water
and like you're happy doing that and you
can still game chicks and
whatever like you know they're playing
mormons with a lot of kids and
and i'm sure they don't have to make
tons of money i mean you have to feed
everybody but
i don't think it's 100 necessary i
always think
like when um when i talk about uh like
what is alpha what's not
and i've always said you know there's
guys there's scoundrel alphas and
there's like
a hero like there's the the upstanding
man of the community kind of alpha right
and that's usually what when women get
to be like in their epiphany phase they
start looking for captain america right
they start looking for superman instead
of batman or
iron man or even the joker in some cases
right i mean
they're looking for a different um alpha
yeah they're looking for the guy who
is leaning more towards the the
provisioning side
they still want a hot guy they still
want some sort of element of like hot
fun excitable
you know sex but that those those
opportunities finding a guy who who
focuses on
who still has um some sort of alpha
gravitas i guess um and is still a good
provider that guy is really tough now
uh to your point rich um do you have to
have a lot of money are there like
outward like are there results is there
residue
right is there residue of your success
and what that means is do you have a hot
car do you have a
nice house how many kids do you have
what can what what do you have in your
life that is sort of like i don't say
receipts but like what is the evidence
what is the
what is the byproduct of you being a
high value guy
and that's going to that's going to be
contextual right because like a guy
who's living
in you know argentina somewhere uh you
know subsistence farm somewhere
that guy still high value guy in
that particular context or in that that
local sexual marketplace there might be
a guy there who is like he's a good man
right he's a good dude he doesn't have a
lamborghini
but by you know by order of degree or by
like
context like by region and by
socioeconomic circumstances that guy
might be the hottest dude in the village
right he doesn't have that he doesn't
have a youtube channel he doesn't have
what a pizza yeah exactly i mean we're
we have to stop thinking
in terms of first world countries and
first world consciousness here because
it's like there's guys like there's
dudes in russia that would like kick
every one of our asses on this on this
panel right now does that make them a
high value guy well i don't know it just
sort of depends on what his
his sort of socioeconomic context is for
the where he's at right now and that's
the difference i think between the local
sexual marketplace and the global sexual
marketplace
so yeah if you have a lot of money if
you have a lot of pull remember wealth
enforces will and wealth is a part of
your
as a as a guy powerful men throughout
history have had three things i think
yeah well money is one of them that's
resources powerful men like chieftains
emperors kings
you know the guy who runs the town kind
of thing all of these guys
it is to be male is to have these three
things and the first one is resources
that's number one
number two is territory and an ability
to protect that territory because those
resources usually come
from the territory that you're able to
expand and defend and then number three
is women lots and lots and lots of women
so
if it's the emperor in you know dynastic
china he's got the forbidden
city full of his concubines guarded by
eunuchs with their dicks cut off so they
can't reproduce with those chicks if
it's uh if it's the cheap and the amazon
rainforest they go and they
create the concubine pen so that the
chief can actually go and nail these
chicks and then by order of degree
right like in your importance if you're
like the king high [ __ ] warrior
maybe you've got some concubines if
you're the shaman you got a few but not
as much as the warrior maybe not as much
as the chief kind of thing
but you're expanding territory you're
expanding your resources and those are
really the three things
that historically have made for a
powerful guy so when we look at like
kings and emperors and chieftains and
all that kind of stuff and now we can
point towards like
we can we can look at career-wise we can
look at things in in terms of career
because now we've become more
you know industrialized and everything
so we but the same dynamic applies
to the powerful man who was the tribal
chieftain as it does to the guy who is
you know the ceo of whatever big major
corporation he's what about influence
though because
because that's one that i didn't hear
you mention really all that too i would
i would say that that's a byproduct of
that
well what about what about machiavellian
ability or ability to
let's say yeah but let's say network or
get in with the right people because
i go i was thinking about rasputin when
he was speaking i'm not sure whether we
put him down as a high quality high
value man but nevertheless he was a dude
basically from the village who came in
to you know and became
embedded in the russian royal family and
and he had the other things that you
mentioned you know he had the women he
had the influence um
he wasn't that he wasn't the top guy he
wasn't the you know the czar or whatever
but he was he certainly finagled his way
in there
so is that sort of machiavellian ability
that ability to influence others does
could that political ability if you like
maybe that plays into
it a bit because you could get the dude
who's not the multi-millionaire he's not
he's not the guy who owns the lambos and
gets that you know gets all
access to all of the clubs but he's
mates with that guy because he's got
very good social skills
and so he gets some of the attendant
benefits
i would say so i think a lot of that
comes down to like sort of being clever
um remember when we talk about the eight
one of the one of the uncomfortable
truths i think about the 80 20 rule that
we talk about in the manosphere for so
long
is um that the guys who are in the 80
percent have to figure something out
they have to figure an end run around
the filter that keeps them from
solving the reproductive problem and
honestly i think a lot of human
intelligence
comes from a necessity to try to figure
out how to get in that girl's pants how
to
and by again by order of degree i'm not
saying all these beta males are trying
to figure out game or something no they
become
innovative they become creative they
become competent in things
that like they create a dishwasher right
or they create a new invention or they
create something that is going to
it raises their status but it raises
their status in a comp
in a competency hierarchy rather than a
dominance hierarchy because they can't
compete in the dominance hierarchy
so instead of trying to be a bigger
batter
uh you know chimpanzee to beat the the
alpha male you invent the gun
right you invent something that can that
can take that guy down
you invent something human intelligence
i think is really
the product of beta males and alpha
males sort of trying to figure out how
to stay on top of the game
more or less and that's that drives
civilization honestly that's one of the
reasons why i think
you know killing patriarchy and putting
you know installing a gynocentric social
order
is really one of the worst things we
could possibly have done for you know
the state of humanity right now because
it kills innovation
it dates the 80 percenters it keeps them
you know jerking off and and
why do you think everything that comes
out of hollywood for the last 20 years
has been a repeat
there's nothing new there's no
creativity that's
the same formula and that's driven by
the need to solve the reproductive
problem
if you remove that need if you satiate
that need you sedate the the that 80
percent
you're you stagnate that's that's when a
society stagnates
give them everything they want yeah it's
going to be even worse with with the
communists or socialism start giving out
you know monthly checks today it's
happening right now people don't want to
go to work right now because
the stemi checks are paying them more
than
the jobs are you don't have to figure
anything out if it's so if it shows up
in your mail mailbox
in the morning you know shows up in your
on your internet
you don't have to you don't have to do
anything you know it's creative for you
i talked about this with ryan on i think
was thursday
um the internet is creative for you
right now
you don't have to be there's no reason
to i mean
unless you're like from a different
generation you have a different you're
of a different mindset and you're
and you're more driven i think one of
the reasons why we have such an audience
like the lost boys audience or they're
so purposeless is because they have
everything pretty much taken care of for
them
you remove them from that state of of i
don't say
satiation but like you remove them from
that state of
having things done for them more or less
they'll find ways
to figure to figure it out that's the
whole reason
for audiences for like you know um for
you know what is what makes for a high
value guy why would guys even watch that
in the first place because they're
trying to figure out
how to be better at something they're
trying to figure out how to do an end
run how to be more competent
how to be more dominant those are really
the two things that i think
from a mental state from a belief belief
state
that's where you got to get there's
plenty of drug dealers
in prison who are alpha males there are
plenty of gang leaders who are out there
plenty of guys
if you were i would argue this if you
were embedded in like
uh antifa right now you would see the
same dynamic play out from within that
group
there's going to be guys who are going
to be more dominant who are going to be
it's a tribe basically to say they're
the powerful guys and what are they
going to have
territory resources and chicks and
they're there
because that's what's going to solve
their problems or what they think is
going to solve their problems from
within that context
so the the sexual marketplace doesn't
change
it's i mean the dynamics of it doesn't
change only the context changes
so if you're in like if you're like in
the goth clubs
or if you're in the nerd culture or if
you're in the amish
i will guarantee you go to the amish
dutch country in pennsylvania the same
dynamic applies
it's just a different context and so so
what are the comments
here's the the operative of this whole
show what are the commonalities
between all of those contexts that that
sort of define
that conventional dominant competent guy
what are those core what are those core
strengths those core competencies
i'm gonna pull you out of the solo
layout and apologize for the super chat
covering your head troy but
uh raft directed this at you asking
about age limit for man to be high value
pulled up a picture there of mel gibson
i don't know what he is there maybe 65
somebody said when that was posted
earlier
i don't know if that's his girlfriend or
just some piece that he's hanging with
at the time but
if you're jacked you have money you have
influence i don't think that age has
much of a bearing on it i don't know
what do you think man
i don't think there's any age limit on
it at all to be honest
i think that uh it's something that you
know until
until the day you die you can be high
value if you look after your
fundamentals
i think even like guys sorry oh i was
saying leo leonardo dicaprio his age
limit for girls like 26.5 yeah yeah i
think
even hugh hefner when he died he was
still surrounded by gorgeous women yeah
yeah story money and chicks yeah yeah
there is there is a difference there is
a distinction
with the playboy mansion we have the
three girlfriends do you think they'd
even put that on tv today
no no no there is a distinction though
between being high value
for for women versus being high value
amongst a group of
of guys i think it's you know because
obviously again
corey worthington you know no doubt
there were girls who was
you know you know sleeping with him at
the time
so in that sense he was high value but
was he actually high value well clearly
not
so it's it comes down to the old thing
isn't it the guys
will value different qualities in
another in another man
that they work with or they network with
or they associate with
then the the things that women find
attractive so
we have to be conscious of the
distinction between those two
varieties of high value and one does not
necessarily
equal the other because you could be
sleeping with a load of women
but you're not high value in any sense
that other guys would recognize or be
amenable to
you